unis mexique a reçu l'honneur
d'organiser la coupe du monde 2026 et
ensuite comme vous le savez déjà on est
dans le vif du sujet en russie avec
l'édition 2018 et autour de moi autour
de la table et bien des experts des
amateurs de foot parlement martinez de
rcm alise polyvalent bonjour ça va bien
ça va très bien merci norberto aguiar
qui lui-même a joué au football et qui
est sa joie les sportifs fondateur de
l'ouzo pressent journal de langue
anglaise de langue portugaise dis-je ici
à montréal le bonjour nos bateaux et
robert frosi qu'on ne présente plus à la
radio la télévision
c'est notre expert tous sports confondus
bonjour bonjour alors robert bon tout le
monde mais d'amis j'ai donc oreiller
aller tout de suite
cette victoire on va dire de l'amérique
du nord pour l'organisation de la coupe
du monde 2026 est-ce que vous avez été
surpris par l'ampleur de la victoire
d'abord robert surpris par l'écart
abyssal entre les états unis et enfin la
candidature nord-américaine et puis le
maroc
on s'attendait à être peut-être un score
beaucoup plus serré alors ça peut
s'expliquer ça peut s'expliquer d'abord
par l'argent parce que c'est surtout
beaucoup d'argent quand on promet 15
milliards de dollars dans les causes
d'or dans les coffres de la fifa et que
le maroc en propose à peine cinq emmy
peut-être que ça la voix de l'argent l'a
emporté d'un autre côté il y avait aussi
ces menaces à peine voilées du président
trump il ya quelques jours avant le vote
qu'ils disaient je me sors l occasion de
me souvenir de ceux qui n'ont pas voté
pour notre candidature et il y en a qui
étaient indécis avant le vote et
peut-être que ces menaces et bien
explique ceci explique cela
mais c'est c'est dommage enfin c'est
bien pour le canada quoique on pourra
alors parler on y voit là c'est
peut-être la première analyse sur cbs et
paloma
je n'étais pas très surpris c'est un
fait je savais que ça allait et salé
d'aller dans ce sens là étant donnée est
justement là que toutes les questions
monétaires vidéo qui étaient mentionnés
par robert aussi donc
mais en même temps j'étais très contente
j'étais surprise mais corps n'est pas
surprise mais très contente
ce serait une troisième coupe du monde
pour le mexique
il faut rappeler à nos auditeurs que
vous êtes mexicaine tiennent donc je
vais cubal celle des 70's mais celle de
80 86 au mexique donc je te contentes de
savoie puis maintenant que je suis ici
au canada ça va être un double victoire
leur berthod mots moi j'étais pas
surprise du tout je m'attendais que
vraiment ce soir voeux aux états unis
canada et mexique de savoir le
championnat du monde parce que scission
si on se souvient quand il ya eu le
dernière choix pour les deux
championnats qui qui sont en sa devait
déjà les états unis et des forces
peut-être aussi au niveau financier qui
ont forcé que ce soit en russie et en
arabie dans le pays
à ce moment-là ça devait être les états
unis
je pense que le choix s'est logé bon
alors les amis vous avez tous entendu
vous entendu parler de la réaction de
diego maradona maradona qui dit le
canada ya des très bons skieurs au
canada c'est parfait les américains
voulaient le mondial de 2014
ils ont fait jouer ils ont voulu nous
faire jouer quatre périodes de 25
minutes pour la publicité
vous voulez qu'on fasse des matchs de
cinq minutes et on sait aussi que les
états unis leur football à eux c'est pas
le football c'est pas de socke est assez
autre chose le sport le plus populaire
et on dit quand aux mexicains selon
maradona il ne mérite pas cette coupe
parce que il gagne deux matches au
mondial et plus sont éliminés
donc pour maradona c'était un mauvais
choix
robert s'est pas que c'est un mauvais
choix c'est le message qu'envoie la fifa
qui fait peut-être ça qu'il faut lire on
s'attendait avec la venue de gianni
infantino le nouveau président que les
philosophies change et que finalement
ces fameuses phrases on dit la fifa elle
pour développer développer son sport et
le faire émerger dans tous les
continents
c'est pas le message qui a été envoyé
pour parce que d'abord les etats-unis
ont déjà eu la coupe du monde
mais peut-être que la fifa nous aurait
montré une image de celle qui veut
développer par exemple continent
africain et peut-être que la candidat du
rpt la candidature marocaine qui n'était
pas la meilleure candidature entre les
deux faut le dire manque
d'infrastructures rénovation des stades
etc
c'est peut-être à ça que ça sert les
milliards c'est peut-être à ça que
devrait servir les milliards de la fifa
c'est à dire pour aider des pays
émergents à aller de l'avant
maintenant moi je suis content
évidemment pour pour le canada mais ce
qui est très très curieux en fait dans
ces candidatures tripartite
c'est que les plus forts sont les
américains et bizarrement sur le terrain
politique on s'aperçoit que les mêmes
pays
l'un veut ériger un mur contrôle mexique
l'autre veut carrément brisé le record
de ces quand même assez c'est quand même
assez fou que ces trois pays se
réunissent et bien pour le canada c'est
bien pour l'essor c'est bien pour tous
les jeunes qui vont être fébrile à
l'idée de se dire on va accueillir une
la coupe du monde
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on va accueillir
véritablement ça c'est le fond du
problème c'est qu'à l'heure actuelle le
gâteau là comme dans les films d'obélix
la bassée américains trois manches des
trois quarts du gâteau et nous il nous
reste quelques miettes mais vous avez
abordé un aspect que l'aspect politique
est ce qu'au fond le sport c'est
unitaire fin le fait de partager cette
compétition peut avoir des effets au
niveau politique et peut-être contribuer
à ce qu'entre les trois pays les
différents que se résolve et c'est dans
longtemps 2026 c'est loin et
la politique calvin un rythme accéléré
surtout avec un président qui prend des
décisions vraiment comme le bihar trompe
qui prend des décisions au jour le jour
il faut suivre ces c'est tendance
et puis au mexique il va avoir des
sélections il va avoir deux sélections
dans les prochains années donc c'est
l'ex-président siège pas donc je crois
qu'il ya beaucoup de temps pour que tout
le spectre politique mexicain canadien
et américain change d'ici là cependant
c'est ce que les trois pays forment une
entité économique depuis si longtemps
donc d'une manière ou d'une autre ça
continuera de l'être
et puis au niveau politique on verra
mais au niveau économique c'est ce que
le mexique le canada les etats-unis sont
une centaine bloc norberto ça c'est
clair quand même que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour le sport le football au
canada
je veux me tenir au niveau sportif
seulement parce que le politique que je
laisse un peu de côté
il faut quand même dire que 2026
trump il sera pas là il y aura de
toujours avec l'esprit plus ouvert au
monde qui change la constitution
américaine et qu'il décide de savais que
si ce tremplin de ce que lui doit partir
alors quand en russie n'ont pas ce genre
de problème en chine n'ont pas ce genre
de problèmes peut-être qu'il pourrait en
tout cas ça dépend des cas de l'irak
au niveau sportif je pense et c'est très
bon pour non seulement pour le canada
qui va avoir la possibilité d'avoir des
matches de niveau mondial mais aussi
pour le soccer au niveau des ailes mls
parce que je pense que c'est vraiment à
partir de maintenant que le les états
unis sortent aux 350 millions
d'habitants qui vont avoir une autre
championnat du monde déjà avec une
championnat national entre guillemets
parce que nationale ça serait juste aux
états unis mais de toute façon je pense
que c'est là parce que les gens qui ont
assisté au championnat du monde de 84 81
94 à ce moment là le soccer aux états
unis c'est pas tellement que ne n'y
avait pas de championnat national mais
maintenant avec un championnat national
avec les assistances qui l'ont à chaque
match je pense que c'est vraiment à
partir de maintenant que le soccer ou à
être un sport majeur aussi malik nom est
robert pour ne les retombées pour le
canada qu'est ce que vous vous
entrevoyez j'entrevois que par exemple
des gens des jeunes qui ont 16 ou 17 ans
qui sont les académies peuvent se dire
et je veux tu être enfin pouvoir faire
partie de l'équipe nationale
maintenant est ce que on sera qualifié
d'office en tant que pays hôte s'est pas
encore déterminée
ça serait quand même bien ce retour
quarante ans plus tard sur la scène
internationale d'une équipe encore à
construire au niveau du canada c'est le
point positif mais je veux vraiment
insister sur le fait de je me demande
pourquoi si on a une candidature
véritablement tripartite que l'on soit
pas dans les tiers de la répartition des
matches de la coupe du monde qu'on
devrait accueillir
pourquoi par exemple les états-unis se
réserve tous les matchs des quarts de
finale à la finale sur leur territoire
et pourquoi si c'est une condition
c'était effectivement équitable pourquoi
on n'aurait pas des matches demi finales
où elle mountain ou à montréal ou à
toronto
ça serait quand même légitime alors
qu'est ce qu'on va se rasseoir d'ici
2026 autour de la table parce que on a
l'impression d'être invités à un repas
de noël mais on va aller manger dans le
sous sol pendant que les américains
mangeront dans la salle à manger
je trouve que c'est un peu déplacé
faudrait peut-être redistribue les
cartes
en fait j'ai une question pour pour toi
robert est ce qu'on aura le temps de
vraiment est-ce que c'est prévu
on peut prévoir qu'il y aura des
négociations à ce niveau là où c'est
vrai car sinon j'espère qu'il y aura des
négociations j'espère que nos
organisateurs et et monsieur bon
tagliani de notre
notre président de soccer canada va être
et début mai ils étaient dans ce nom il
est le président de la confession
fédération lui dit qu'il a plus pouvoir
il est vice président de la fifa alors
j'ai silsilah pas le moyen de se battre
pour que le canada et sa part je
comprends je comprendrais mal
ok on est d'accord mais c'est dans la
candidature qu'en faisait le choix des
candidatures le canada à moins contribué
le canada le mexique au moins contribuer
financièrement ce qui expliquerait cette
disparité au niveau de la qualité enfin
au niveau de la quantité la qualité des
matches qui on va quand même payer 150
millions de dollars
le mexique aussi pour dix matches donc
on contribue quand même on va quand même
rénové un stade olympique pour le mettre
aux normes de la fifa et aux exigences
de la fifa
donc à partir le soir - là on peut pas
dire que qu'on accueille l'événement à
moitié on met toujours pour que
justement ça soit on respecte les normes
on développe et c'est alors des
retombées en plus économiques qui seront
formidable pour nous pour nos trois
villes au canada donc non je crois qu'il
faut effectivement se bat pour pour
essayer d'avoir au moins des matchs de
quarts dé finale ou en demi finale oui
j'ai peur d'une chose c'est que je cloud
et respectueux mais j'ai cloyes que le
championnat du monde et devaient être
aux états unis ici le canada et le
mexique qui sont qui ont accroché
l'association américaine de soccer pour
des urbains écoute et pourquoi pas faire
ça à trois et à partir de là le canada
et le mexique était déjà aux perdants
parce que le championnat devait être
allé aux états unis et le canada a dit
bon on n'a pas le pompeux là les moyens
d'avoir le championnat du monde au moins
on va voir mais non ça c'est c'est comme
ça que tout a débuté n'oublie pas nos
berthod que c'est un mondial à 48
équipes
est ce que les états unis avaient
forcément les moyens
de d'accueillir 48 équipes probablement
parce qu'ils sont quand même une
quinzaine de stades qui sont prêts mais
mais tout de même je pense que en étant
une candidature tripartite s'il faut pas
oublier qu'on a 48 équipes à accueillir
avec les infrastructures avec ba c'est
quand même beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de monde
robert mais si les états unis n'ont pas
ces moyens comment le maroc
les orcs et c'est pour ça que la
candidature marocaine est en train de
discuter peut-être éventuellement
puisque y est on a appris qu'ils vont se
représenter pour 2030 ce qui selon moi
est une erreur parce que l'uruguay sur
le a déjà posé sa candidature avec
l'argentine et le paraguay et 2030 c'est
le 100e anniversaire premier match
première coupe du monde c'était en 1930
en uruguay donc sauve hier de joselyne
pic en grèce on reviendra sur / le
blocage du maroc mais juste avant d'y
aller est ce que
on parle souvent du soccer qui n'est pas
le sport est d'importance amérique du
nord
c'est à dire sans sport professionnel
d'accord mais c'est un sport de seconde
zone par rapport au football américain
par rapport aux quais par eurobasket au
baseball ainsi de suite est ce qu'au
fond ce sport là selon vous de façon
générale robert surtout robert est
énorme et vous l'avez vu grandir
est ce que c'est un sport qui va
finalement avoir la place qu'ils
méritent un bris d'une horloge il l'a
déjà il l'a déjà chez les jeunes c'est
devenu le sport numéro 1 le requiert et
relégué là c'est plus le sport national
il faut dire qu'aujourd'hui le sport
national c c'est le 5 1 en plus on a des
équipes maintenant professionnel on a
des ligues
on a des jeux d d d d équipe qui évolue
dans la mls
une d'ailleurs une mls qui a monté et
qui a grimpé de manière spectaculaire au
niveau son niveau de jeu avec la venue
n'ont pas de joueurs en fin de carrière
ce qui était le cas au début mais
maintenant deux joueurs effectivement
qui ont encore comme on dit qu'on a
encore sous la semelle
parce que ils nous donnent un spectacle
extraordinaire et on a fait monter le
niveau avec l'arrivée de ces nouveaux
joie et avec aussi la formation nos
joueurs que ça soit l'académie de
l'impact que ça soit ce qu'on fait à
toronto ou à vancouver c'est fantastique
et l'essor on le voit cc je pense que de
notre temps pour les petits vieux que
nous sommes là mais c'est vrai que l'on
croyait pas à cet essor l'âme
nécessairement on savait que ça allait
prendre des décennies d'ailleurs ça a
pris des décennies pour arriver au
résultat qu'on a aujourd'hui qui est
spectaculaire
on peut dire aujourd'hui qu'on commence
à revenir dans la planète à part qu'il
faudrait maintenant qu'on l'appelle le
football et non pas le soccer voilà
alors oui mais norberto à propos de ce
que
vous venez de dire je je vous rappelle
que en ce moment le championnat de la
mls
c'est le sixième au monde au niveau
d'assistance
il ya plus d'assistance que le
championnat d'italie et juste devancés
par les glandes championnat d'angleterre
le primaire c'est l'endroit angleterre
espagne mexique
hihi et puis c'est les états unis donc
c'est ce qu'est ce que pourquoi pourquoi
on discute encore baisser c'est parce
que les médias
ils sont par là on voit ici
j'écoute les télévisions on parle encore
du sport qui est le championnat du monde
reut mois avec 32 équipes
c'est beaucoup plus que les jeux
olympiques mais aussi on insiste pour
dire que les jeux les jeux olympiques
sont plus importants
non c'est pas plus important et je veux
dire dire aussi que c'est que pendant
les 15 jours que les jeux olympiques
sont là il ya des occasions qui a pas
beaucoup de gens ont stats et les
matches
les trois matchs de chaque jour au moins
ils ont cinquante mille personnes 60 me
par sont tout le temps sa demande que le
soccer est très important mais ici on
insiste pour le relégué en 3e 4e ya plus
de jeunes qui pratiquent le soccer
aujourd'hui au canada qui ceux qui
pratiquent le hacker donc ça commence à
être quelque chose d'important dans les
vingt 20 ans que je vécu dans ce pays je
vu un changement radical quand je suis
arrivé il y avait très peu de personnes
qui pratiquaient très peu de personnes
qui en parlait à part les communautés
culturelles qu'on appelle mais
maintenant c'est quelque chose de plus
large au canada il ya beaucoup plus
d'intérêt
puis évidemment les clubs professionnels
sont là comme robert le 10ème et c'est
en général quelque chose qui commence à
prendre de l'ampleur des plus simples au
canada ajouté m
très prochaine génération alors un
continent où le football est roi c'est
l'afrique l'afrique à organiser une
seule coupe du monde il a fallu
l'implication personnelle de nelson
mandela pour que ça se fasse en afrique
du sud
sinon le maroc qui est toujours
l'éternel candidat et qui est toujours
rejeté
alors robert a abordé le sujet tout à
l'heure qu'est-ce que ça prendrait pour
qu'une candidature africaine fonctionne
une volonté politique des membres de la
fifa et que ça soit plus l'argent qui
soit le mètre le mètre étalon mais qu'
on y aille un peu plus chez un peu
d'angélisme la vie qu'on y aille un peu
plus avec avec la philosophie la coupe
du monde même s'il ya des éléphants
blancs aujourd'hui en afrique du sud
avec des stades qui sont moribonds a été
je dirais été une réussite totale a été
une réussite totale à tous les niveaux
parce que on a fait taire cette idée que
le continent africain est pas capable
d'accueillir un événement de cette
taille là on a montré que pour répondre
à un an berthod que l'afrique pouvait
effectivement accueillir accueillir une
compétition de cette envergure
aujourd'hui il va falloir que les
mentalités et change qu'on arrête de
parler d'assistanat et qu'on est qu'on
dise voilà 6,6 à d'emilia les les fameux
15 milliards entre autres qui vont avoir
dans les coffres de la fifa c'est sans
compter les droits de télévision etc et
et qui sont énormes et ben donnons les
justement à l'essor de pays
moi je rêve oui le maroc avec une
candidature tripartite tunisie algérie
ou alors ou alors la côte d'ivoire le
sénégal est pourtant sur le terreau
politique ça s'est réchauffée même entre
l'algérie et le maroc parce que le
président bouteflika a envoyé des
émissaires pour dire nous allons
soutenir votre candidature et tu vois
par le complètement et le geste a été
accueillie est à même d tendu les
relations bilatérales alors je trouve
que c'est fascinant alors si on pouvait
encore là sans faire d'angélisme se dire
que des pays belligérants en afrique
réunissent pour accueillir un événement
mondial ça serait quelque chose de
formidable et moi je vous assure robert
que seraient des effets au delà de
d'au-delà de la politique sous le plan
social bien sûr à l'insu du sud c'était
une candidature dans plusieurs pays
c'est la solution pour l'afrique parce
que c'est comme pour démontrer qu'on est
unis juste manas et la scotia 48 pays et
pour l'europe
c'est 2,3 pays dans le futur c'est juste
deux trois pays au monde qui ont le des
moyens les moyens de faire c'est de
s'amuser à 48 euros et puis les gens ne
sont plus dupes eux parce que là on
parle d'argent public aussi est donc on
l'a vu que avec l'olympisme et les jeux
olympiques ou les pays ne se bousculent
plus maintenant
contrairement à avant où c'était un
prestige de recevoir de lune est un
événement comme celui-là ça reste
toujours un prestige noms se bousculent
plus pour être la ville hôte de deux de
ses jeux et on s'aperçoit
qu'effectivement ballet l'argent public
les gens à se disent y est on a
peut-être d'autres priorités sociales
avant d'accueillir un événement de
quinze jours qui va de toute manière ne
pas être rentable c'est pas la même
chose pour la coupe du monde mais parce
qu'il est rentable mais par contre on
doit se dire que les gens ne sont plus
dupes et donc s'il ya de l'argent public
à investir il faudrait effectivement que
ça soit équitable sur les trois pays par
exemple
et puis que les résultats comme vous le
dites au niveau social seront
fantastiques
voilà donc une sixième candidature
marocaine seul ce serait un peu de
l'acharnement ces reptiles
il faudrait voir si on ne peut pas
s'allier à d'autres pays il ya une autre
chose
c'est pendant ce championnat qu'une
équipe africaine arrive au moins quart
de finale pourquoi pas demi finale
si une équipe africaine fait ça c'est
sûr qu'ils vont regarder de notre
manière on a failli avoir le ghana en
en afrique du sud ouais ça ces joueurs
sont fait voler ils sont fait voler par
le cameroun aussi à quelques années à
quelques années alors effectivement bon
ça nous amène à parler justement de la
compétition actuelle qui a commencé en
russie bon ça commençait très très fort
pour la russie 5 0 face à l'arabie
saoudite
bon avant de parler de vos choix vos
pronostics
qui est ce que vous voyez se démarquer
dans chaque continent pardon si on prend
on va dire l'europe quel pays quelle
équipe européenne voyez vous c'est aller
le plus loin possible robert évidemment
jeu sera pas original ce que je vais
raconter
c'est sûr que la mannschaft l'allemagne
est extraordinaire parce que ils ont un
bassin
ils ont quasiment deux bancs deux bandes
joueur il pourrait effectivement avoir
une équipe pas une équipe b ça serait la
même équipe ils ont énormément de talent
maintenant les a vus dans leur phase de
qualif dans pas dans leur phase de
préparation
sap a été les résultats escomptés se
donne un peu jeune et quand on dit une
équipe jeune je la compare par exemple à
la france équipes jeunes beaucoup de
talent mais on joue pas ensemble
il ya plus de rigueur dans la mannschaft
la plus haute de rigueur dans
l'allemagne donc si un pays devait se
démarquer ça serait sans doute
l'allemagne mais attention
est ce que le portugal enfin va faire
fuir ses démons parce que ils ont des
démons en coupe du monde c'est que plus
on se rapproche de la de la partie
finale et plus c'est même plus de
nervosité rendu à ce niveau là alors est
ce qu'ils ont trouvé le bon psychologue
pour ronaldo ou le bon psychologue pour
l'ensemble de l'équipe se dire on est
capable maintenant d'aller jusqu'au
final on l'a vu à l'euro où il était
capable d'aller jusqu'à une finale et la
gagner donc
moi je dirais attention portugal quant à
l'espagne bat on verra et la france
robert je vous le dis la france si si
tout le monde se met à jouer ensemble si
on laisse les égos de côté parce qu'il y
en a beaucoup
il y en a des gros notamment à l'attack
griezmann mba paix quand tu aimes bape
et va comprendre que eh bien ça joue pas
tout seul
et griezmann aussi est qu un ballon ça
se distribuent peut-être qu'ils vont
finir par le maître dans le fond voilà
tu vas la main je ne suis pas une
experte voulait savez je ne vois là des
parents des coups de coeur des coups de
cages et évidemment je crois l'espagne
puis je crois au portugal parce que donc
j'ai désespoir me ce ces deux pays
voilà nos bateaux dont moi j'aimerais
que le portugal surpris du monde c'est
difficile c'est difficile ça dépend de
beaucoup de choses
c'est un pays latin le sens et les
choses marchent pas bien ça commençait à
douter
c'est difficile mais c'est vrai si
ronaldo il arrive à maintenir son niveau
c'est sûr qu'il peut déséquilibrer le
match et c'est lui qui peut décider du
portugal peut aller jusqu'en finale et
gagner le championnat du monde mais à
part ça il ya deux équipes très fortes
en europe
je pense la france la france c'est
peut-être l'équipe qui a d'après moi le
plus de talent dans l'ensemble si fait
un bond équipe peut-être pas et on a vu
dernièrement avec les jeunes des états
unis l'on était pas capable de gagner
des jeunes de 22 23 ans des états unis
c'est chez eux chez eux
en plus c'est pour ça que je doute que
la france arrive là au titre mais c'est
une équipe que j'aime beaucoup et qui
happe des très bons joueurs
à part ça j'aimerais que l'angleterre
aux mains fasse quelque chose parce que
c'est le pays de sault caire et si on
retire le champion le championnat de
1966 plus rien alors pensé que ce grâce
à ce jour en matière de trophées de
victoire finale ça se joue toujours
entre l'europe et l'amérique du sud
maintenant on va du côté de sud
américains qui est ce que vous voyez se
démarquer quand mon coup de coeur pour
les avoir vus pour les avoir vus prendre
7 1
au brésil chez eux
il faudra qu'ils se remettre de ça mais
quand neymar va c'est comme un peu le
portugal de ronaldo quand neymar va le
brésil va et les brésiliens je les ai
vus jouer et j'ai l'impression qu'ils
reviennent avec et là c'est mon âge qui
va qui va me trahir mais avec cet esprit
qui avait le brésil quand on a commencé
à le découvrir dans les années 70 c'est
à dire un jeu plaisant des joueurs
heureux de jouer et je j'ai ressenti ça
en regardant quelques matches de
préparation de l'équipe brésilienne on à
présent d'avoir retrouver cet esprit
brésilien c'est la fête quand on joue et
tout alors vont-ils garder ce côté je
dirais de fêtes d'enfants pendant le
mondial s'ils le font pour moi ils
seront en finale
maintenant il ya évidemment l'argentine
de messi on ne peut pas passer à travers
messi qui est épouvantable dans le sens
où il peut tout faire à lui tout seul
faire basculer un match
et c'est un génie du ballon est-ce que
encore une fois lui aussi ils ont des
choses à prouver est ce que là encore le
réveil argentin bon pourquoi pas mais et
puis bon il ya des petites équipes - je
sais pas je fais pas pour lui faire
plaisir mais mais c'est vrai que le
mexique
moi je fais attention je serai
l'allemagne la suède ou la corée du sud
ferait très attention au mexique dans
leur gros point fort
alors voilà mais évidemment j'ai pour
mon coeur va pour le mexique je sais
qu'ils ont des grains des opposants
c'est fort justement le premier match
mexique c'est l'allemagne donc déjà
sonné
danger cependant je pense qu'ils peuvent
peut-être pousser fort parce qu'ils ont
une bonne équipe il ya des bons talents
chez les mexicains
sinon effectivement la l'argentine 6
réussi à se dire que au delà des
messieurs renault une équipe derrière
lui parce que c'est pas juste lui s'il
6e mais pas ensemble c'est une grand
talent cet homme là cependant les sauts
de joie pourrait jouer un rôle très
important pour l'argentine si il décide
de faire équipe
et puis le brésil ouvre on veut tous
qu'ils les barelvis le favori naturel
d2d presque tout le monde
norberto mais qu'est ce que je veux dire
de plus l'argentine c'est les deux pays
non seulement au niveau de l'amérique du
sud mais au niveau mondial ces deux pays
que son top tout le temps
ces deux candidats vraiment très fort
s'ils vont gagner je ne sais pas au
niveau 2 du mexique je parle pas parce
que il ya un autre collègue
c'est juste parce que appartient à
concacaf concacaf c'est nous et c'est
pour ça que j'aimerais que le mexique
face bien de figure pour que la concacaf
commence à gagner de poids dans la fifa
s'est vu c'est ça à part ça j'aimerais
que s'ils gagnent par le portugal
ça c'est bien une équipe africaine ça ça
serait vraiment mais je rajouterais il
peut être que si on devait pointer du
doigt quelqu'un qui pourrait bien jouer
les trouble-fête et renverser tout ce
qu'on est en train de raconter autour de
la table pour moi ça serait la belgique
qui a des joueurs extraordinaires on
n'en a pas parlé
il se prépare de manière complètement
folle est ce que les diables rouges vont
nous sortir quelque chose
si oui pour moi ça serait peut-être
l'équipe qui va falloir surveiller sur
la surprise du mondial pourrait venir de
la belgique à la parlant de surprise ce
serait une grosse surprise si on avait
un vainqueur qui venait du bloc
asiatique
alors qui est ce que vous voyez parmi
les équipes asiatiques comme équipe qui
pourrait se démarquer qui peut sortir du
lot la corée du sud
les coréens nous ont montré des choses
extraordinaires depuis qu'ils sont en
coupe du monde
en plus ils sont infatigables il faut
moi je devrais je ferai passer des tests
pour voir s'ils n'ont pas trois poumons
si chaque joueur n'a pas trois m'ont
tellement ils sont c'est le cas de le
dire époustouflant mais leur un peu plus
de technique et ils vont être
redoutables ils font leurs classes les
coréens du sud - chaque fois que je les
vois jouer me font peur parce que ils
peuvent affronter en plus ils ont un
mental
si c'est le brésil qui en face ou
l'argentine ou l'allemagne on joue comme
des corps est un peu importe le score
aussi on arrête par oui on arrête tout
mais alors l'écho rien oui dans le
continent asiatique certainement là si
je connais très peu les effectivement
les coréens sont dangereux pour leur
force mentale parce que comme comme
norberto 18 halak et les latinos les
latins ont comme les sens un peu chaud
pis on en a pas on a besoin d'un
psychologue à côté de nous tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps pour nous
pousser les équipes c'est comme ça donc
mais les coréens c'est pas ça habille
les japonais en plus donc les japonais
pourraient aussi faire la soupe pris la
meilleure équipe en ce moment en asie
c'est le sida l'ira l'ira mais je ne
sais pas je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils vont
aller loin
surtout dans un groupe qui a le portugal
et l'espagne
cl c'est dans une autre groupe peut-être
nous aurait pu passer ma voix que si ça
veut dire que mais moi mon équipe d'asie
que j'aime et que se fasse bien c'est le
japon j'aimerais que les gens parce que
le japon a aussi besoin on peut de ce
que le
l'amérique du nord a besoin pour
vraiment pour que le soccer soir bien
installé et pour nos n'arrêtait plus
amateurs du genre maroc fantômes dont
sous le bloc africain qui est ce que
vous voyez sortir faire bonne figure
pour le sucre dans le continent africain
et là je m'excuse tout de suite auprès
de tous les auditeurs africains
le problème avec les freaks et qui sait
qu'elle est imprévisible
ok ce sont des joueurs qui ont chacun
leur tempérament
donc s'il ya 23 joueurs sur deux de
sélectionner il ya vingt-trois
tempérament mais qui vont être
influençable
c'est à dire qu'en fait ils vont tous
influencés et des fois si les africains
se mettait à jouer d'abord comme des
africains c'est à dire avec le mélange
du brésil la technique de européenne
parce que il faut la force physique
complète ils ont tous ils ont toutes les
qualités pour justement se rendre même
en finale d'une coupe du monde seulement
le problème c'est qu'à un moment donné
ils vont prendre un bus il va se passer
quelque chose ils vont perdre un joueur
est là là c'est comme si le monde venait
de s'écrouler et que l'équipe là tout
d'un coup je sais même plus comment où
et mon pied gauche mon pied droit et
tous ses talents là s'éteignent d'un
coup alors moi je mettrais une énorme
génératrice là parce que s'il ya une
panne de courant au moins on sait qu'ils
vont continuer à jouer j'aimerais ça
avoir des équipes c'est sûr que le
nigeria est évidemment l équipe
inhabituelle d'ailleurs qu'à sortir qu'à
sortie si je ne m'abuse le cameroun est
là j'ai fait quand même deux grosses
puissances
donc attention nigeria j'aime beaucoup
le sénégal parce que parce qu'il ya de
la folie dans leur jeu j'aime bien ils
ont ils ont du latin quand il se met à
jouer dix ans ils ont de l'afrique est
orpheline stone il faut dire pourquoi le
latin non mais ces deux équipes là ouais
moi effectivement mais surtout le
nigeria qui mériteraient parce que ça
fait un moment qu'ils qui cognent à la
porte justement de ces fameuses demi
finale qu'on n'a jamais vu encore avec
une équipe africaine mais moi et mes
pronostics j'avais le sénégal en octobre
des finales puis le nigeria aux quarts
de finale donc je crois que c'est c'est
dur mais je ne sais pas plus loin que
les quarts de finale
voilà ça c'est une autre question noah
jusqu'au match d'aujourd'hui j'ai côtoyé
beaucoup à l'egypte mais était joué très
bien j'ai vu le match porto portugal
l'egypte ils ont pris de but
en surtemps mais ils ont très bien joué
très bien joué je pense qu'il ferait
match nul aujourd'hui isolé encore des
chances mais avec la défaite et les cinq
bus de la russie ça va être très
difficile mais ça serait mon équipe
j'aimerais les voir aller c'est sûr que
maintenant c'est très difficile on
n'aurait pas l'egypte mois défaite
contre les russes les russes nous ont
bien un coup d'éclat d'entrée faut pas
oublier que c'est l'arabie saoudite
donc ça veut dire que si l'egypte bat
l'arabie saoudite pourrait très bien
surprendre les russes - les russes
failli ils nous ont fait un super numéro
je suis très content parce qu'on n'avait
pas vu l'équipe russe on les connaît pas
ce sont des joueurs qui veulent une que
je ce que j'ai peur c'est l'obligation
de vaincre
c'est ça le problème ça peut lui nuire
c'est pour ça que j'ai on peu peur sur
l'équipe d'egypte à partir de zéro
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai quittée
j'étais j'ai regardé le match mais j'ai
quitté dix minutes avant c'était c'était
j'ai croisé beaucoup passent en revue
les groupes ont fait allusion à la
russie dans le groupe la russie on à la
russie l'uruguay et l'egypte et l'arabie
saoudite
est ce qu'un consensus qui sort qui sort
en tête ou qui quels sont les deux
équipes qui se démarquent
moi j'ai mis russie et l'uruguay
évidemment ce n'est pas parce qu'il est
le résultat mais effectivement russie
aurait eu elle devrait être logiquement
les deux équipes mais en tout cas pas
fini pour l'egypte moi je moi je
continue à croire l'egypte même si je
sais que c'est difficile et bien sûr
l'uruguay a good by on a le portugal
l'espagne
l'iran et le maroc là aussi sur papier
c'est facile de dire oui mais le
problème c'est que tout va dépendre en
fait du résultat de tout à l'heure c'est
à dire portugal portugal espagne c'est
le gros choc en fait de ce premier tour
en coupe du monde
imaginons
une dégelée d'un côté comme de l'autre
un match nul
match nul ça veut dire que tu viendra
donner toutes les cartes parce que c'est
pas vrai que tout de suite on va dire le
portugal ou l'espagne mon bac le maroc
où l'iran facilement l'iran et le maroc
on l'a dit ils sont là ils sont pas là
pour faire de la figuration donc tout va
dépendre en fait pour le portugal et
l'espagne 2 qu'est ce qui va se passer
comme résultat entre les mots évidemment
je sais d'où là j'avais 10 et mes coups
de coeur et européennes ça continue
d'être mon coup de coeur pour le groupe
2 cependant je crois qu'il ya des
surprises du maroc pourrait venir de
marocains effectivement norberto bon en
86 le portugal a appelé 3 0 après trois
bus de du maroc et le portugal étaient
favoris ça veut dire qu il faut toujours
se méfier mais je crois vraiment que le
portugal si c'est pas jojo à ce moment
avec cristiano ronaldo
ça va être dit m maintenant ou jamais où
on va dire groupe s'il veut juste mettre
une note c'est que lila il ya un
entraîneur qui veut avoir des comptes
avec le portugal c'est un risque et au
grain bon alors on va voir ça groupe c
france pire au danemark australie moi je
vais vous étonner
oui mais les français aussi talentueux
qui sont je les sens pas ils sont trop
confiant il se voit déjà en finale de la
coupe du monde
ils vont peut-être prendre leurs
adversaires
veut vraiment au dessus je me méfie de
deux équipes
le pérou et l'australie je sais que je
vais peut être faire rire mais le pire
ou ça fait 36 ans je pense qu'il avait
30 ans à qu'ils étaient pas venus ils
ont ils sont étonnants est ce qu'ils
peuvent arriver à déstabiliser une
équipe de france et les australiens
alors là moi je les ai vus jouer les
australiens son redoutable talentueux
technicien costaud surtout très physique
et ça là je suis pas sûr que ils vont
aimer les français dans leur premier
match
enfin j'veux pas sûr que les français
vont râler parce que eux ils lâchent pas
et en plus ils sont super physique et
les grandes stars que sont m bape est
lui encore moins il est capable d'en
prendre mais griezmann dès qu'il est un
petit peu taquiné là il fait un peu plus
attention alors quand ils vont tomber
sur les bûcherons et fabien ils vont pas
trouver ça drôle alors méfiance bon
alors oui mais je pense que la france va
quand même passé mais c'est sûr que le
père eut beau le ballon au pied et ils
ont des bons joueurs il faut faire
attention c'est ça c'est mon choix de
mes choix et la france et le vernis
violet groupe b argentine croatie
islande nigeria moi je donne l'argentine
soit le nigeria sortant de ce groupe
l'islande ils nous ont fait un super
numéro cellule à l'histoire des casiers
amateurs c'est le petit poucet ils vont
pas nous refaire le coup de l'euro et
puis la croatie bas
c'est vrai qu'ils sont ils sont costauds
mais
non franchement argentine nigeria sans
aucun pas j'hésite les argentiers ont
peur des six lames d j'ai entendu
plusieurs sages dantin faire des
commentaires j'ai eu lieu de crohn égard
gentille fille les esprits ce que
l'islande a fait en aura donc mais il
peut effectivement à moi c'est céline
nigeria comme j'avais dit et puis là
chantier par l'argentine je pense c'est
le groupe le plus équilibré
ces trois équipes que chacun d'eux peut
passer et c'est très difficile de
choisir une des trois mais je veux pour
la croatie
alors on va vers la finlande est rendu
au groupe e avec le brésil la suisse
costa rica et la serbie basile ce sur va
sortir j'espère en tout cas qu'il va
sortir premier de son groupe
maintenant moi j'hésite un peu mais
c'est sûr que les ticos je les adore
costa rica là ils sont fantastiques
ils sont passés à chaque fois proche de
l'exploit etc
j'espère que cette fois ci vont aller
loin dans cette coupe du monde
ils sont inspirants ils sont beaux à
voir jouer alors moi je moi je donnerai
le brésil costa rica
même si effectivement faut se méfier de
la nati la suisse où effectivement la
nati comme ça qu'on appelle l'équipe
suisse et
et il pourrait jouer les trouble-fête
absolument
moi c'est le grèce et la serbie et la
serbie quoique pourrait surprendre quand
même c'est une bonne équipe donc je
crois que ça pourrait sur ok regarde moi
là par le brésil costa rica c'était
l'équipe que j'aimais le plus au plaisir
et en étant une équipe de concacaf
moi j'étais derrière malheureusement
elle a eu deux c'est comme ça le hockey
il a été éliminé mais moi c'est cette
fois ci j'en prends pas costa rica même
si je veux qu'elle le vendre comme je
vous dis lappartient concacaf et ça mais
je pense que c'est le brésil la suisse
d'accord allemagne mexique suède corée
du sud
bon je sais que je vais tout de suite je
vais tout de suite parce que sinon je
vais recevoir encore dit tous sauf la
suède et l'italie
je vais soutenir mes camarades tout sauf
l'achète je vais y aller avec
l'allemagne et le mexique même si j'aime
les petits coréens du sud mais ça se
peut pas que l'allemagne sort pas de ce
groupe puis ça se peut pas mal mais
c'est surtout parce que j'aime beaucoup
palop
c'est bien ça c'est bon ça tu te ménages
ttt relation groupe g ici je pense que
non limitée unanimité cc l'allemagne et
le mexique
le groupe j on a la belgique
l'angleterre la tunisie et panama moi je
dirais que belgique angleterre sont les
deux incontournables et belges qui ont
un joueur comme hazard ou kevin de bruz
que c'est que tu veux faire c'est ils
ont comme je dis ça peut être l'équipe
surprenant et puis bat l'angleterre il
serait temps qu'ils se réveillent parce
qu'il faut qu'ils enlèvent le
l'humiliation de sortie au premier tour
du dernier mondial
donc là et puis ils ont des joueurs de
talent quoi puis c'est chez eux qu'on a
inventé le soccer il serait brouillé le
panama première participation je pense
qu'ils vont faire de la figuration dans
le groupe i la tunisie bah je sais pas
mais que ce soit le panama effectivement
mais je suis réaliste de la belgique il
à l'angleterre de sa technique du club
belgique et angleterre aussi même si le
panama appartient concacaf sur
l'angleterre je pense qu'il manque des
tacticiens
c'est ça le problème les entraîneurs
anglais sont des entraîneurs de deux
ballons dans les airs qu'annick et puis
quand défaut défend de résultats ils
sont pas capables d'inventer de parce
que y'a ya beaucoup de manières des
ventes et même jure-t-on qui tomba à
terre x laisse pendant une minute pour
arrêter de que notre équipe court vite
et si l'on passe à l'amérique latine pas
qu'on sait que c'est toujours un bon
joueur qui est l'entraîneur en ce moment
peut-être lui il a eu des entraîneurs
qui l'a vu comment travailler peut-être
l'angleterre pourra cette fois ci faire
quelque chose de bien voilà il termine
avec le groupe h pologne colombie
sénégalais japon ce groupe le plus
ouvert en tout cas de toux de tous les
coupes du monde de la coupe du monde
sénégal colombie pour plein de raisons
d'abord parce que j'aimerais que parce
que je crois beaucoup au sénégal comme
pays africains qui qui peut nous faire
des belles surprises la colombie parce
qu'ils ont des supers joueurs encore là
on en a pas parlé de la colombie mais
mais pologne équipe qui pourtant conquis
ont des traditions quand les supers
joueurs le japon belle japon je pense
pas qu'il soit encore rendus là
peut-être que je me trompe mais comme on
n'en voit pas beaucoup du soccer
japonais donc c'est difficile à dire le
grand bain et moi on s'est croisé à la
caf et tmc pas parlé on s'est pas dit
nos pronostics qu'on a les mêmes
pronostics mais aussi pour ce groupe
moi je suis monté donc je suis manque à
la colombie et le sénégal et la colombie
oui et je crois qu'ils ont un bon équipe
ils pourront faire bien et l'autre
équipe
on peut de 2,2 ma volonté c'est le japon
j'aimerais que le japon passe avec la
colombie alors la question qui va vous
départager certainement qui est ce que
vous voyez en finale et qui va
l'emporter
ben normalement sera dû être l'italie
mais ils sont pas là parce que c'est
vrai est une coupe du monde sans
l'italie ce n'est pas une course facile
a complètement une formule 1 ferrari
quoi ça fait mal au coeur mais bon on
attendait 4 ans pour soi m non le brésil
moi je verrais une finale j'aimerais ça
une finale brésil avec un pays africain
quoi ça sert - c'est me final j'ai
portugal brésil argentine mexique
un final j'ai dû me de partager c'est le
brésil argent c'est mon souhait plus
glacée l'argentine c'est qu'ils
gagneraient donc dans cette
confrontation entre loi est très
difficile
j'aimerais que ce soit blessé mais je
crois que ça va être la mère de partage
qui va départager
alors berthod moi je pense que c'est le
portugal à la bonne tête
je pense que l'important rapport à
arriver la finale avec l'argentine ça
serait cristiano ronaldo merci écrit
sont à gagner évidemment en finale
ça mais si je l'espère leur berthod et
paloma robert merci beaucoup d'être
venus et va vous prêter à ce jeu c'était
un plaisir et à vous rend vous dis à
bientôt
merci d'avoir été là merci